there's no let up on the Eastern Front
Line
the ukrainians are making strong
progress they've got the Russians on the
run and they're pushing them further and
further back into the donbass
they're still managing to take them by
surprise
ambushing Russian vehicles and trapping
their troops
the ukrainians were laying in wait for
these Soldiers the Russians are being
massively outmaneuvered here
and the ukrainians are pulverizing their
enemies
they're on the doorstep of lahansk with
the town of cremina in their sights and
it's the gateway to the region
as far shows the two sides are in very
close contact
[Music]
there's constant shelling
and there are jets in the air
those are all bombs raining down around
the city
everything will be Ukraine he's shouting
to us
the Russians are suffering significant
losses nothing not even threats of
nuclear attacks are enough to deter the
ukrainians
they're emboldened by Victory and
prepared for whatever comes their way
foreign
but thoughts of death are never far away
are you that is
the challenges facing the Ukrainian
troops are only likely to grow
they're already considerable with the
seasons changing military vehicles are
often the only way of getting through a
lot of this territory
and these two will start struggling soon
so there's a race to keep ahead of this
deteriorating weather which will make
all this even more impenetrable
stop the advance not the lack of
determination or the wave of momentum
that they're riding it's this mud down
here and the cold which has dropped
around the water
the front line residents are now burying
the Russian soldiers they're finding
often Under Fire
he came to our land to kill Anna tells
us
she'd only just retired now she feels
lucky if she lives through each night
that's
Battlefield success rarely comes without
a heartbreaking cost
Alex Crawford Sky News in Tosca on the
Eastern Front Line